Mary is well as Mary's in Dallas hi Mary
how are you I'm great Dave good to get
to talk to you you too
what's up well my husband is retiring he
had his business or I'm gonna say 35
years now and we as part of that we went
ahead and did a small building which
we've been you know running his business
out of so we actually went to and talked
to a realtor about it a commercial
realtor and we actually sold it before
it actually even went on the market Wow
that that's how hot real estate is in
Dallas right now wonderful and what you
do with the business did you sell it the
business no it's actually a service
business so it's not really it maybe I
fell in a job okay so they just closed
hell yeah yeah we're just he still and
we're still in the process of
liquidating we've got a lot of customers
that are upset that we're going out but
you know he's going to be 66 in
September and you know time times time
for a break
this works very very hard what is the
commercial building bring three hundred
and thirty three thousand cash one so we
were pleased to get a full cash offer so
and it's paid for we don't have any debt
good so we're a city we also have
including including that 300 and we I
think we headed around 350,000 estimates
but anyway we have around 1.1 million in
real estate now that we're we've
liquidated a portion we're going to be
liquidator portion of that we close here
and you know in a couple of weeks other
than real estate what do you have in
retirement I want to say I mean I know
we've got a total of about 10 point 1
million in assets phenomenal way to go
Mary congratulations John when y'all
started out did you have anything excuse
me did you did you start out rich oh god
no now this is just hard work yeah you
started to join here I did you inherit a
bunch of money no no no no he's not only
a service what kind of service business
did he have do the pair services
or on the control systems for utility
companies Wow they would they yeah
they'd find the the bad boards and
they'd send them to him and then he
picks them and shows a nice little
business but unfortunately what happened
a lot of our stuff was too cold business
and we all you know coal coal plants are
just you know they're dying by the day
yeah yeah okay and I just always like to
ask a millionaire how they got there so
it's very cool congratulation I don't
feel like I am walking yeah no you
started from nothing you worked your
butt off your whole life and you're
worth two million dollars
congratulations how can I help you well
we want to take portion of this might
have some fun with it for a change
absolutely we kind of figured it's time
so we're we're doing that probably you
know but after all the closing phase
it's going to be about three hundred and
eight thousand and then we're going to
about 20k and taxes on that I'm a CPA so
I can't myself okay so I make a current
way I'm still working and probably will
work for the next few years and I'm
making around 125 thousand year
phenomenal okay so you know obviously
hidden comes going down and mine is
going to remain steady until I'm ready
to retire and then I get a small pension
when I retire with a very small pension
but so I guess I will want to do is just
kind of we want to get an RV okay
obviously we're not going to get a new
RV what do you think I'm spending on the
RV well my husband is kind of thinking
all the way up to about a hundred and
fifty thousand I think you know I think
you should I think you should buy
$150,000 RV and it has nothing to do
with anything except it's a very very
small percentage of your world it's
about eight percent of your net worth
yeah whoopee yeah I know you drive it
off a cliff without insurance your life
does not change this is true okay so the
point is an RV is an RV as in the
vehicle and RV as an investment is in
the same category of boats and airplanes
right it's sighs it sucks it's going to
go down in value so
fast it's going to make you puke right
but so what you want an RV you get an RV
you worked your butt off your whole life
for two million dollars it's a small
small percentage of your life you're not
going you're not going to finance it
you're going to pay cash and if it if it
does nothing but burn down in the
driveway you owned it and it didn't
affect your life it's a small percentage
of your world that's how you define
whether you can afford it or not and
this is a total car this is a toy well
yeah and to me it's a big toy like I
said I'm I understand her you know
marriage and just like ease is this yeah
but you're you're also you also look
like I did at it you saw depreciation on
four wheels that's what you saw because
it is just doing here it is absolutely
ludicrously bad as far as money goes but
you can afford it and if that's your
idea of fun at 66 years old working your
butt off starting from nothing and
having two million dollar net worth then
get one and do it I don't do ten of them
do one but have the fun and enjoy every
minute of it you've earned it this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income on a five hundred
thousand dollar income
you